et ont détaillé de leurs embouts mène la
bataille sociale de la rentrée elle est
déjà engagée
mais les syndicats sont divisés pays
basque espagnol encore un attentat ce
matin la population basque pourtant
saturé de violence mesdames et messieurs
bonsoir ce week-end devrait marquer les
premiers grands retours de vacances
bison futé vous conseille de ne pas
prendre la route autant que possible
demain sauf si vous y êtes vraiment
contre un de plus le temps sera très
médiocre il pleuvra des vosges alsace et
des alpes à la corse
laurent broomhead le temps de ce mois
d'août après des soins pour ceux qui
sont en vacances
est-ce que ce mauvais temps est
exceptionnel est-ce que ce retour en
force non pas des vacanciers mais des
pluies marque que nous sommes déjà
presque dans l'hiver nous coûter tout de
même pas ce n'est pas encore l'hiver que
vous savez en météo il n'y a jamais rien
d'exceptionnel en fait la situation qui
lie à cette année on a déjà eu d'autres
années se reproduira sans doute encore
mais c'est vrai autant le mois de juin
aurait été beau temps le mois d'août et
décevoir et beaucoup de nuages et
beaucoup de pluie en particulier dans la
moitié nord du pays puis finalement là
où il faisait beau dans le sud il y
avait le vent le mistral et les
incendies voici les images transmises
par l' agence spatiale européenne
transmises par les satellites meteosat
aujourd'hui de 9h à 14h vous voyez une
bande des nuages qui passent sur la
france d'ouest en est
elle donnera encore des puits demain
matin dans l'est et puis vous voyez une
éclaircie après mais plus loin sur
l'atlantique d'autres nuages si vous
dire que le week-end comme le disait
tout à l'heure dans les titres et bien
malheureusement ce qu'elle sera décevant
alors lancé comme vous êtes et ce que
vous pouvez nous donner vos prévisions
région par région
oui bien d'abord sur l'est du pays comme
vous disiez des vosges aux alpes et à la
corse encore un ciel très nuageux demain
avec des orages et quelques pluies mais
ces nuages partiront vers l'est et donc
les éclaircies reviendront dans cette
région région maintenant vallée du rhône
et régions méditerranéennes du soleil
toujours avec du vent et tout de même
quelques passages nuageux ensuite dans
l'après-midi troisième région de
l'atlantique au massif central aux
pyrénées là un ciel nuageux d'abord avec
des hits la cigm ensuite devenant plus
nuageux avec l'arrivée comme vous le
voyez tout à l'heure et et satellite
d'une zone de nuages qui va venir
envahir ces régions enfin dernière
région de la bretagne au bassin parisien
au nord et à l'est
un ciel plus agréable
des nuages c'est vrai mais aussi des
éclaircies les températures seront plus
basses demain matin que les autres
joueurs mais plus élevées l'après-midi
en particulier dans le nord ouest
dimanche
le même temps continu c'est-à-dire
finalement variable avec à peu près
partout des nuages et une même des
éclats est-ce que vous pouvez nous vers
une prévision avant d'avancer une pour
la fin du mois car il ya d'autres
français qui doivent partir en vacances
pour la fin du mois peut-être pas en
tout cas pour lundi je crois qu'on peut
espérer mais c'est vraiment quelque
chose qu'on avance à tâtons je crois
qu'on peut espérer une amélioration du
temps au moins temporaire en particulier
sur le sud
wavre tout semble prêt ce soir pour que
le nos vrais ex france puissent partir
le refus des remorqueurs de la compagnie
des abeilles pour aider le navire à
sortir en pleine mer a été contournée
par l'armateur norvégien mais ce
commerce
il nous l'avait annoncé d'ailleurs
lui-même ici hier soir dans l'interview
qui nous donnait il a fait appel
dit on a deux remorqueurs de haute mer
français qui seront aidés par deux
remorqueurs néerlandais arrivé ce matin
le dispositif de départ est donc en
place
les membres de l'équipage du north bay
ont indiqué qu'ils étaient requis à bord
pour un appel général ce soir à minuit
cette convocation au poste de manoeuvre
doit précéder le des doublages des
amarres c'est à dire le retrait
progressif des haussière qui retiennent
deux navires à quai ainsi l'ex paquebot
france va donc d aller comme l'on dit du
quai de l'oubli sans doute demain matin
sauf si la météo et des très mauvaises
car cette éventualité compliquerait la
tâche des remorqueurs de haute mer
en effet traîné au bout d'une longue
remorque une masse aussi inerte et aussi
imposante que le paquebot n'est pas
chose facile loin de là les risques de
rupture du câble de remarques ne sont
pas négligeables et c'est sans doute
pourquoi les assureurs du paquebot en
stipulé que le norway ne devrait pas
sortir du havre si le vent était
supérieur à la force 5 quelles que
soient les circonstances et le respect
qu'on doit aux lois internationales
ce n'est pas sans un pincement au coeur
que les français verront partir vers
d'autres cieux et sous un nom étranger
ce bâtiment qui avait été l'orgueil de
la marine marchande française
en tout cas je prends par une dépêche
qui vient de tomber que toutes les
oeuvres d'art tableaux et tapisseries
notamment seront intégralement restitué
à la compagnie générale maritime
le nouveau propriétaire du locle la
semaine qui se termine a été très animée
sur le plan social les déclarations se
sont succédées à un rythme de
mitrailleuses peut-on dire dès le 7 ou
monsieur séguin avait annoncé que ce
mois ci ne se termineraient pas sans
manifestation est bien prévisions
confirmées par la prochaine grève dans
les chemins de fer avant la rentrée mais
ces déclarations ne signifie pas qu'il y
est un front commun syndical
loin de là puisque ni la cfdt ni la fn
estime avoir été consultés suffisamment
sur une éventuelle action commune avec
la cgtr pour nous y retrouver au milieu
de ses différentes prises de position
je vous propose de suivre le film des
principales déclarations est le premier
coup de semonce syndicale aura lieu du
22 au 24 août pendant trois jours avant
même la rentrée les cheminots seront en
grève à l'appel de la cgt de la cfdt et
des agents de conduite autonome pour le
moment c'est la seule action unitaire
prévu des manifestations comme celle-ci
avec georges séguy edmond maire et andré
henry main dans la main ne sont pas au
calendrier de la rentrée sociale georges
séguy a annoncé hier que la cgp fera
cavalier seul une semaine d'action du 3
au 7 septembre avec un rassemblement le
5 place de la république
une campagne d'information et de
recrutement pour soutenir deux
revendications principales
une augmentation des salaires de 200
francs par mois et une allocation
scolaire de 600 francs par enfant
quant à l'unité syndicale affirme
georges séguy elle n'a pas été possible
tant des contacts ont eu lieu entre
organisations syndicales
il s'est avéré est la suite de ces
conversations que les autres
organisations n'était pas dans l'état
d'esprit d'organiser aussi promptement
une riposte syndicale la cgt juge
indispensable sans attendre longtemps
après la rentrée
pourquoi nous avons été apprend amené à
prendre notre initiative qui n'est pas
contradictoire utilisation qui nous
l'espérons débloquera la situation et
permettra ultérieurement des initiatives
unités d'actions de plus grande
envergure
ce matin la cfdt a vivement réagi à ces
propos
nous n'avons pas été consultés par la
cgt pour une éventuelle action commune
affirmé jacques chérèque le numéro deux
de la centrale selon lequel l'action
efficace est autre chose que le
défoulement sporadiques
qu'est ce que ça signifie au point de la
démocratie syndicale un état major qui
en pleines vacances lance un série d'une
série d'initiatives à disposition que
nos gens apprennent sur les plages
qu'ils sont incapables de confronter
avec les travailleurs nous préférons
nous actuellement travailler avec ceux
qui sont présents est faire en sorte que
dans les entreprises nommées du temps
avec les travailleurs à la rentrée une
série de propositions sur les salaires
les conditions de travail qui permet de
cette mobilisation dans les branches
industrie qui permette de déboucher ne
sommes pas hostiles à des mouvements
beaucoup plus conséquent que cette
espèce de show-business syndicale qui
peut conduire à à une esbroufe
un feu de paille ou qui veut conduire à
l'inéluctable journée d'action
défoulement tous les mécontentements
même son de cloche à la fédération de
l'éducation nationale qui a reçu les
propos de monsieur séguin avec le plus
grand étonnement andré henry affirme lui
aussi que la cgt ne l'a pas consulté
andré bergeron lui avait pris les
devants
la situation sociale risque de devenir
dangereuse at-il prédit au gouvernement
n'est pour autant force ouvrière n'est
pas prête à s'allier avec n'importe qui
nous ne changerons pas notre politique
c'est à dire c'est à dire que nous ne
ferons pas nous ne pratiquerons pas
l'unité d'action avec la cgt
du côté des cadres de la cgc la grogne
est sérieuse
jean menu a prévenu que pour défendre
leur pouvoir d'achat
les cadres étaient prêts à s'allier aux
syndicats ouvriers
cela dit l'unité syndicale n'existe pas
et le gouvernement compte bien sur les
mesures prévues en septembre pour calmer
l'agitation sociale
monsieur georges séguy fait écho
aujourd'hui aux récentes déclarations
faites sur un thème de par le surinam et
du travail et réitérée par le ministre à
france inter aujourd'hui il est prêt à
rencontrer monsieur séguin et celui ci
réponde aux ministres notre rencontre
peut avoir lieu immédiatement si votre
intention est vraiment de négocier mais
il faut bien préparer notre entretien
et monsieur séguy souhaite discuter avec
monsieur boulin ministre du travail d'un
relèvement substantiel du smig et d'une
réduction de la durée hebdomadaire du
travail
jusqu'à présent le patronat étaient
restées muettes les leaders
syndicalistes certaines personnalités
politiques occupait ce qu'on appelle le
devant de la scène aujourd'hui monsieur
yvon chotard vice président du cnpf où
il est chargé des questions sociales a
critiqué et les déclarations que vous
venez de revoir en images que nous vous
avons résumé estimant que le vrai
problème était celui de la compétitivité
les entreprises françaises sur le plan
international à ce propos une petite
mise en garde adressée au gouvernement
il ne faut pas alourdir davantage les
coûts de revient sous peine de voir
baisser notre compétitivité
vous savez chacun des à la même époque
il ya une série de déclarations
au delà du verbe il faut voir la réalité
la vérité sur la situation économique
qui est la nôtre
cette situation est grave elle est
difficile mais il n'y a pas de
satellites et de la crise nous pouvons
gagner la partie
notre partie de la bataille économique
mais à condition que chacun en ait
conscience fasse des efforts et ce n'est
pas par le désordre des services publics
où des manifestations de différentes
natures que on maintiendra notre
compétitivité et on gagnera cette partie
de la bataille économique justement au
niveau économique on a l'impression que
parfois le entre le gouvernement et le
cnpf il n'est pas du tout d'accord on ne
prend pas les mêmes optiques
c'est bien simple notre optique nous
elle est simple on ne peut pas continuer
à frapper 116 sur l'entreprise
chaque fois qu'il ya un problème trouvé
comme solution une charge nouvelle pour
l'entreprise
il faut maintenir la compétitivité des
entreprises
et c'est la seule garantie et du coup
maintien du pouvoir d'achat et du
maintien de l'emploi
regardez l'allemagne il y a quelques
années l'allemagne a pris une position
déterminée de préserver des entreprises
de leur permettent les restructurations
et le résultat le bénéfice
ils l'ont aujourd'hui pas plus de 3 % de
demandeurs d'emploi plus de trois cent
mille offres d'emploi non satisfaites
l'allemagne se trouve aujourd'hui en
situation de plein emploi est bien ce
que nous demandons ce que nous disons
c'est que les entreprises françaises
doivent être en état de se battre pour
gagner
le bureau politique du parti communiste
a décidé de convoquer de la prochaine
session du comité central pour le
mercredi 12 septembre à l'ordre du jour
le développement de la lutte et de
l'unité d'action pour la défense du
pouvoir d'achat des travailleurs et des
familles la participation de bokassa 1er
au massacre d'une centaine d'enfants en
avril dernier dans l' empire
centrafricain est quasi certaine telle
est la conclusion de la commission
denquête constituée de magistrats n'a
pris qu'un le président de cette
commission mucyo n'diaye aux magistrats
sénégalais nous a exposé ici même hier
soir par téléphone les détails souvent
atroce et toujours accablants et qui ont
amené ses collègues et lui à conclure
comme il l'a dit
mais le conseiller juridique de bokassa
1er monsieur mamba cas mabhouh a répondu
il n'y a pas de preuve formelle de la
participation de l'empereur à ces
massacres
cet après midi paris a pris la mesure de
suspendre l'aide financière et d'état
centrafricain à la seule exception des
opérations concernant la santé
l'éducation et l'alimentation c'est à
dire ce qui concerne directement la vie
de la population il faut souligner que
l'état centrafricain est l'un des plus
pauvres pays du monde et que la france
prend soin de distinguer entre les
crédits à l'état qui sont suspendus et
les crédits destinés à la population
laquelle ne doit pas être à famille
abandonnée sur le plan de la santé de
l'école il y a des limites strictement
humanitaires cette décision et on peut
aussi noter que la condamnation morale
de bokassa s'est faite au niveau
africain à travers une mission de sage
et n'ont pas d'état en état bref sans
aucune puissance ex coloniale et eu à
intervenir
enfin je rappelle qu environ trois mille
ressortissants français se trouvent en
centrafrique dont 400 coopérants le
nicaragua se relève difficilement des
événements du mois dernier qui avait
abouti à la destitution du dictateur
somoza les pertes dues aux destructions
et à la paralysie de l'industrie comme à
la guerre civile sont considérés
un fonds international de reconstruction
a été constitué afin de recueillir
toutes les aides financières qui
parviendront là bas le gouvernement
français a décidé d'envoyer par avion
une aide d'urgence au nicaragua elle
comprendra des médicaments et des vivres
et elle sera suivie par un nouvel envoi
d'environ 1000 tonnes de céréales
d'hiver
monsieur yang ambassadeur des etats-unis
à l'onu démissionnaire hier sera
remplacé dit-on formation bac emery qui
était son adjoint et qui comme lui est
un homme de couleur
quoi qu'il en soit monsieur yang a
vivement critiqué ce matin la politique
étrangère du gouvernement 4 pers dans
une interview publiée par plusieurs
journaux américains pour lui par exemple
c'est la lenteur de washington à renouer
des relations diplomatiques avec le
vietnam qui est la cause de l'exode de
millions vietnamiens de plus monsieur
yang qui reste en poste jusqu'au début
de septembre est toujours prêt en tant
que président en exercice du conseil de
sécurité a rencontré à nouveau le chef
de la mission de l'onu monsieur terzi si
celui ci le demande la démission de
monsieur janda provoqué beaucoup de
réactions
nous vous avons donné depuis hier cette
d'israël voici celle de monsieur sous ce
chef du bureau de vlp à paris sur ce
limogeage
je pense que ça c'est la preuve la plus
flagrante de l'énorme de l'immense
affluence que le lobby sioniste à sur le
grandement des états unis mais tout de
même cette rencontre de matching avec le
délégué palestinienne n'était pas la
seule rencontre officielle de
l'ambassadeur américain avec un
représentant du lp y en a eu d'autres
il ya eu un contact entre un responsable
de l'onu et l'ambassadeur des états unis
vienne comme l'ont révélé les américains
eux mêmes il ya dans toutes les
conférences internationales dans toutes
les organisations internationales des
contacts à tous les niveaux chaque fois
qu'il ya une délégation de l'oif pays
une délégation des états unis en
présence l'une de l'autre
il n'est pas étonnant d'ailleurs que ces
scandales sur le contact qu'a eue avec
représentant un nu ait lieu juste en ce
moment là car les israéliens se sentent
à ce moment-là isolé sur la scène
internationale et ils ont peur que le
conseil de sécurité puisse voter une
résolution qui stipulerait d'une façon
très précise les droits palestiniens
c'est à dire le droit le tout dernier à
l'autodétermination de droit au retour
et le droit à établir un état
indépendant est souffrant vous voulez
dire que avec ou sans les aveux de
machines young il ya eu tout de même
quelque chose qui a bougé malaty ville
américaine vis-à-vis des palestiniens
sous l'administration carter tout montre
que carter a voulu faire des progrès
dans un certain sens que je pense qu'il
a fait un mauvais chemin
d'abord en
en encourageant l'accord séparé entre
l'egypte et israël et en europe à
poussan vers une solution de global du
problème
iran cinq cent mille personnes se sont
prosternés ce soir dans le centre de
terrain à la fin de la grande prière
publique de cette journée consacrée à la
palestine et ce sous les portraits
géants des sr arafat de l'arménie celui
ci appelle les musulmans à renverser
tous les gouvernements corrompus et
irène par ailleurs la situation au cours
distance et aggravé les guerriers cure
de partisans de l'indépendance et qu'on
appelle les pêcheurs ont pris d'assaut
la ville de pavés tuant 50 personnes au
gouverneur iranien de la province a
admis qu'une dizaine de gardiens de la
révolution blessés dans les combats
contre les kurdes ont dû être évacuées
enfin les cures de rétablir un avion
fonds tome 4 des forces armées
iraniennes et un hélicoptère et les deux
équipages auraient péri le gouvernement
tente d'acheminer des renforts mais les
kurdes tiennent des routes et ces
renforts ne peuvent pas à ces nouvelles
attentes à la nuit dernière à bilbao au
pays basque espagnol la victime ce carré
d'as qui a trouvé la mort dans cet
attentat
passer pour être relié avec les groupes
d'extrême droite
on approche du référendum sur
l'autonomie du pays basque est la
question qui se pose est de savoir si
les extrémistes de l'été un vont peser
davantage que les modérés lesquels sont
un clin à s'accommoder du statut
d'autonomie qui leur est présenté par le
gouvernement de madrid
c'est à cette question que veut répondre
envoyé spécial permanent en espagne
bruno albin qui vient d'enquêter pour
nous au pays basque
une fête de village à quelques
kilomètres de bilbao petite localité
industrielle petit fronton mur gris il
faut l'entousiasme des joueurs de pelote
pour faire croire que l'on s'amuse dans
ce décor noircis par la fumée des usines
au dessus du fronton trois lettres
noires pence sur fond blanc le thé à
elles ne sont pas là depuis longtemps
sous la dictature nommé l'organisation
clandestine équivalait à la prise mais
l'immense majorité des bases que
soutenait secrètement la lutte de l'été
a pour affranchir le pays de
l'oppression france aujourd'hui
le taa presque pignon sur rue les
calicots qui rappelle la lutte armée des
terroristes flotte dans les rues sur les
places publiques des panneaux
entretiennent le souvenir des militants
de l'organisation arrêtés par la police
et lors des élections municipales
démocratique les partis politiques qui
appuient la lutte armée des séparatistes
ont recueilli près de 20% des voix et
conquis le fauteuil de la mairie dans
une vingtaine de villes c'est le
cabernet ni 31 mille habitants le maire
et président d'une assemblée dominée par
les indépendantistes chaque réunion est
prétexte à affirmer cette volonté
d'indépendance
fallait-il ce jour là accroché au mur le
portrait du roi symbole réglementaire et
obligatoire de l'unité de l'espagne les
uns les nationalistes modérés
l'affirmait les autres la majorité
jusqu'au boutiste s'y sont opposés on a
transigé dans ce conseil dominé par les
marxistes en accrochant pas crucifix
mais le portrait du roi est resté dans
un coin de la salle il y à des villes du
pays basque ou vouloir parler de
réconciliation frise de rationnel
la démocratie espagnole ils la refusent
en bloc et le maire d'hernani ballet
d'une phrase des efforts des politiciens
modérés qui ont négocié le nouveau
statut d'autonomie qu nous sommes sûr
dit il que ce statut ne nous apportera
rien positif alors pour faire adopter ce
statut par les basques ce statut dans la
majorité les partis nationalistes pense
qu'il peut être considéré comme un
traité de paix avec l'espagne il faut
marginaliser les tenants de la violence
d'ici au référendum du mois d'octobre de
réunion en réunion les militants des
partis modérés ils veulent faire
connaître ce nouveau texte des électeurs
et surtout profiter du nouvel état
d'esprit de la majorité des basques qui
de plus en plus repousse la violence et
aspire à la paix civile
au début je soutenais le terme est
aujourd'hui affirme cet homme c'est
différent dans tout a des limites et la
violence qui fut les innocents à coups
de bombes dans les gares n'a plus lieu
d'être et le statut d'autonomie peut
s'il a ramené la paix au pays basque oui
il le pense c'est un statut limitée est
valable le jour du référendum il n'y a
pas de doute qu'il votera ou ce mettre
fin à ce climat de guerre civile larvée
et purgeant chaque jour les basques en
subissant un peu plus les effets cet été
à saint sébastien les plages sont
restées désertes pour cause de
terrorisme
cette région l'une des plus riches
d'espagne est aujourd'hui dans le
peloton de tête pour le chômage et les
faillites d'entreprises
le pays basque est un pays dont il faut
reconstruire l'économie c'est possible
l'autonomie peut le permettre
à condition que le ter déposent les
armes et cela seul les basques peuvent
aujourd'hui l'obtenir
une mesure d'expulsion a été prise à
l'encontre du nationaliste recettes
j'avais apprend t-on aujourd'hui à la
préfecture des pyrénées atlantiques
toutefois dans la mesure où il ne
trouverait aucun pays d'accueil monsieur
charest pourrait demeurer provisoirement
en france mais il devrait résider à ce
moment là en dehors des neuf
départements du sud ouest hier à naples
madame anatrella a établi un record est
ahurissant et peu enviable celui d'avoir
eu en deux accouchements 14 enfants
il est à environ deux ans et demi elle
avait mis au monde des sextuplés qui
moururent tous très vite cette fois ci
elle a eu huit enfants en une fois à
l'heure actuelle six d'entre eux
survivent encore de précision par gérard
dalmate un risque sur 20 millions 971
1520 grossesse de donner naissance à
huit enfants d'un coup c'est pourtant ce
qui est arrivé à une napolitaine de 28
ans désespéré de ne pas être mère et qui
avait choisi la seule solution possible
bousculé le mécanisme naturel avec un
traitement hormonal contre la stérilité
dès 1975 résultat en 76 premier
accouchement de six enfants aucun
survivant
pas découragés par cet enfantement
dramatique
la jeune femme a récidivé en reprenant
le risque de la même chimiothérapie
décidée par les spécialistes face à la
détermination de cette patiente mais la
nouvelle espérance était à nouveau
multiples elle s'est achevée à sept mois
par une véritable portée huit enfants
cinq filles trois garçons deux filles de
450 grammes sont mortes et les médecins
sont réservés pour les chances des six
survivants des octuplés sauf peut-être
pour les plus gros si l'on peut dire
deux garçons de 11 cents grammes
seulement qui montre une certaine
vitalité
souhaitons leur nombre ou la nature elle
fait bien les choses et des erreurs
qu'elle commet c'est à dire donner à une
mère simultanément 5 6 8 enfin sont fort
rares
ce sont des hommes avec leur
chimiothérapie qui provoque la plupart
de ces grossesses bestial le record du
monde appartient en fait à une
australienne qui en 1971 avait accouché
de neuf enfants dont aucun n'a survécu à
naples comme en australie
c'est un vêtement hormonal contre la
stérilité qui était à la base de ces
grossesses pas comme les autres des
explications du professeur en riant dans
un premier temps ont fait grossir l'oeuf
qui vient du centre de l'aveyron a fait
grossir en surface grâce à une certaine
catégorie d'hormones qu'on extrait des
urines de femmes ménopausées vie dans un
deuxième temps qu'on fait pondre l'oeuf
avec une deux
catégorie d'hormones que l'on extrait
design de femme enceinte
la nature fait habituellement bien les
choses nous voici mais de temps à autre
nous surdoses ont un petit peu nos
médicaments et le résultat est de faire
monter à la surface d'un verre plusieurs
jeux et de faire pondre à la femme
plusieurs heures jusqu'où peut-on aller
trop loin pour ce traitement pour ne pas
transformer les maires en monstre disons
et éventuellement leurs enfants tout est
une question de ou prescription
il faut choisir les traitements il faut
choisir les femmes qui on applique ces
traitements ce sont des femmes qui ne
portent pas spontanément duff ou pondent
malheureux ensuite il faut choisir les
doses et enfin il faut surveiller très
attentivement cette catégorie de
traitement le champ des médicaments
excellent qui ont totalement changé ce
type d'austérité que nous appelons des
stérilités ovarienne au début de mes
études mais heureusement déjà plus de 20
ans et une femme qui ne voulait pas
qu'ils ne comptaient pas d'oeuf ou
n'avais aucun espoir d'avoir un enfant
donc à mon avis c'est un progrès tout à
fait considérable
la rançon de ce progrès est une certaine
prudence et deux temps à autre même avec
de la prudence
un résultat les vassaux espérance en
raison des faibles effectifs de la
police et ressent je laisse les
personnes privées de délire industriels
et particuliers ont recours pour leur
protection à des sociétés de police
privée comparer avec des services de
surveillance tels qu'ils existent chez
nous les vigiles américains ont des
pouvoirs considérablement étendu en fait
en ce moment aux états unis c'est
presque tout le système de la police
américaine qui semble remise en question
le gouvernement fédéral de washington
vient même de menacer la police
officielle de philadelphie
depuis plusieurs années une industrie
florissante se développe à los angeles
c'est un peu partout dans les grandes
villes des états unis
une industrie anti-violence destinés à
la protection des citoyens
west coast ici est dirigée par un ancien
chai nous avons 2 125 agents détectives
et gardien nous avons la possibilité
d'accomplir toutes sortes de missions de
l' enquête criminelle jusqu'à la
protection des maisons des propriétés et
des magasins mais aussi prévenir les
vols les privées utilisent les méthodes
les plus sophistiqués pour être engagé
comme gardien ou détective il vaut mieux
être un ancien de la police mais aucun
diplôme n'est exigé
l'examen de passage obligatoire pour
tout le monde et le détecteur de
mensonges laquelle les réponses aux
questions se font par oui ou par non
suggère alors avez vous dit rien que la
vérité toute la vérité
l'envoyer sur la question numéro 5 il ya
eu mensonge délibéré
et encore le même exemple pour la
question numéro 4 pour les enquêtes
criminelles on utilise un autre procédé
électronique
le détecteur de stress dans la voix un
informateur qui appelle est aussitôt
analysé sur la petite bande de
l'appareil s'inscrit les moindre
hésitation où les mensonges
l'activité principale de la compagnie et
de garantir la sécurité des biens et des
personnes pour cela on n'hésite pas sur
les moyens à employer à beverly hills
une personne suspecte a été aperçu dans
un jardin privé
il n'en faut pas plus pour déclencher
l'opération on y va de la réputation de
la west coast et aussi de sa publicité
auprès des personnes rare non encore
protégés
à
chacun
dans ce quartier beaucoup de vedettes de
cinéma jack lemmon est un client de west
coast ainsi que le fameux inspecteur
columbo peter falk qui paie ses
cotisations sa contribution à la
tranquillité chaque propriétaire de
maison paix une vingtaine de dollars par
mois environ 100 francs le prix pour des
gardiens armés de fusils à pompe et à
cartouche de chevrotine
avant l'installation de patrouille on
comptait 20 25 cambriolages tous les
deux mois maintenant les chiffres sont
tombés à 3 ou 4 l'investissement est
rentable à tout moment les patrouilles
peuvent investir les terrasses et les
jardins personne n'a idée de s'en
plaindre ici si l'on a envie d'être
protégé on paye il n'y a pas d'agent de
police payés par les contribuables en
bas des maisons des personnages
importants ce qui est surprenant c'est
la liberté d'action qu'on les vigiles
sur les personnes privées
ils ont la possibilité d'arrêter des
suspects un seul droit dont ils ne
bénéficient pas celui à l'erreur car les
victimes pourraient réclamer des
dommages et intérêts importants
l'entraînement des agents de west aus et
élémentaires ils savent que pour fait
une arme implique une responsabilité
morale c'est à peu près tout et cela
semble suffire puisqu'il n'y a pas eu de
bavure jusqu'à présent des gardiens dans
les usines cela n'a rien de surprenant
pour les français ils sont ici pour
éviter les vols c'est bien clair mais ce
qui est le plus surprenant c'est contre
cash à personne que parmi le personnel
il ya des agents de west coast qui
observe méthodes discutables mais
efficace les vols ont cessé et c'est un
grave problème aux états unis oui les
employés qui volent c'est un problème
sérieux aux états unis à combien se
montent les vols chaque année ces vols
se monte à environ 10 milliards de
dollars
mais que fait la police d'état dans tout
cela
on peut avoir l'impression qu'elle
laisse la part de la sécurité à d'autres
et qu'elle pourrait bien y perdre son
autoritaire mais c'est là sans doute une
vision d'européens les privés ne
viennent pas ici au contraire
ils sont très utiles ici à los angeles
les effectifs de la police officielle ne
suffisent pas ils sont parmi les plus
faibles des états unienne les impôts ne
sont pas prévues pour protéger les
entreprises
alors pour sa protection l'industrie
doit faire appel et c'est la meilleure
des solutions à la police privée dans
votre mission au nom il complète notre
travail
ils ne sont pas officier de police cela
doit être entendu mais dans cet état
tous les citoyens comptent autorités
pour procéder à des arrestations dans
certains cas pour nous la police privée
est un complément les contribuables
semble content et aussi car les taxer de
police sont faibles la multiplication
des organismes de protection ne
risque-t-elle pas de constituer en
elle-même une menace pour les libertés
ici on a choisi jean gachassin michel
crauste pour tous les amoureux du rugby
voilà deux noms qui suscite de grands
souvenirs souvenirs d'un réduit à la
française attac d'apam h rugby champagne
demain à l'occasion de leur jubilé
jacques chancel vous propose d'assister
sur antenne 2 à partir de 13h30 à cette
grande fête du rugby au cours de
laquelle vous pourrez voir le match
revanche de la finale 79 narbonne
manière commenté par roger couderc et
pierre albaladejo bien sûr résumé de la
météo de n'est pas laurent broomhead sur
la france demain après des pluies
matinales débauche aux alpes et à la
corse temps frais et variable
les averses ont surtout localisées de la
bretagne au site central et aux pyrénées
larges éclaircies sur le languedoc
maison provence températures en baisse
à 23h hervé claude vous donnera les
dernières informations demain antennes
2010 vous est présenté par daniel
bilalian et demain à 20 heures si tel
est votre joie
nous nous retrouverons ici même bonsoir
merci